مووووو
مُو مُو  مُو مُو  مُو مُو
يَا بَقَرَاتِي  يَا بَقَرَاتِي
مَاَ احَلَاكِي مَاَ احَلَاكِي
مُو مُو  مُو مُو  مُو مُو
يَا بَقَرَاتِي  يَا بَقَرَاتِي
مَاَ احَلَاكِي مَاَ احَلَاكِي
مُو مُو  مُو مُو  مُو مُو
في مرعاك مُو مُو بين الأعشاب الخضراء
مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو
من ردد في المرعى مو؟
يَابَقَرَاتِي
مُو مُو
أَشْتَهِي مَنْكِي
لَحْما طَيِّبٌ
مُو مُو
وَتَكُونَ لِي أَحْلَى غِذَاءً
مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو
من ردد في المرعى مو؟
يَابَقَرَاتِي مُو مُو
لِلْفَلَّاحِ مُو مُو
دَوْمًا عَوْنًا مُو مُو
في حُقُولهَ اَلْخَضْرَاءَ
مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو
من ردد في المرعى مو؟
يَا بَقَرَاتِي مُو مُو
امرحي دوما مُو مُو
في مزرعتي مُو مُو
في الصباح و في المساء
مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو مُو